all right
we've just hit 4 million subscribers
which means that we'll have an epic best
of seven game match between Otto and
Mika besides from fighting for owner and
his amazing trophy you guys voted the
loser to face his fear and jump off the
plane from 4 000 meters who will win
this match I think it's gonna be a good
game we're both in our top form so
that's it
oh my God
good luck good luck I think airmail
should guess who's gonna win if he gets
it wrong he also has to jump off the
plane how did this turn like this why am
I in Arizona I'm not even playing I'll
guess
thank you for the trust ever if I lose I
won't have a chance alone gonna jump
with me if I lose no no no no no no no
okay oh it's intense
okay so we both know what's on the line
loser
falls off a plane neither of us wants to
lose this oh this is exciting okay
oh
that's a way to start the game he is not
messing around starting off the match
with a bomb okay one zero
[Music]
I'm actually regretting my choice at the
moment family you're stuck with me now
unfortunately yes
[Music]
what's going on here I don't know what
was foreign
uh backhand as well 4-0
sorry yes the first one yeah
reassuring not everything comes
I'm going home okay the Sensei is
looking pretty strong now I have to say
I played the best backhand I could what
was that
foreign
what's happening actually I don't know
what's happening oh so clearly doesn't
want to jump off a plane
okay here we come sir good sir seven
five
just give him there
whoa
oh
so close I should have just it's hard
now I know I have to say it couldn't be
much more even than this at the moment
what a point just standing there we're
gonna play that's the seven why would I
waste my energy exactly first game goes
to the Sensei until we play until four
sets I haven't won anything yet except
the first set come on show your magic
let's do this let's go let's
was it okay it was
sorry
no spin from the net
I right
how can you focus
you play in Germany so
long question
that was that was French
good placement
easy mistakes good job receives not that
optimistic anymore no no
oh what a point that's great oh my God
that was an important for me I know
foreign
look at that beautiful footwork
I could give you two points for that
[Applause]
oh nice one one the sets couldn't be
more even than this what happened there
I don't know I missed one then we could
just kept the ball on table and add it
all to miss this how's your confidence
now it's better than the first set he
has showed signs that he's a human being
we have a chance here game number three
okay will the Sensei make sense of his
game again or will Magic Mike show his
magic
what a point kaboo
one table that's how you win points
that's a very good point actually
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
it's still not over this set
it's not all worse it can be
nice
[Music]
already I gotta start doing some sounds
myself
okay come on
yeah yeah yeah
come on
I don't know what that was I thought I
was trying to go as hard as I could but
very interesting
um was it over the table maybe not
[Music]
whoa
ten
oh I got a bit scared on that one after
her
good shot though now it's 10 11. oh
[Music]
he put no spin on it the banana no spit
so two one one the Sensei takes the lead
big set big set who's gonna get the
trophy
just keep it on the table main tactic
against the sensei
that's also a good tactic sorry
oh
thank you
[Music]
oh
hey serve
sorry hmm
showing slo-mo replay it was like almost
on the table's leg
s
big point
[Applause]
okay
it's getting intense it's very intense
now that is a rattle
[Music]
this is what everybody wants to see nine
all
nice
[Applause]
oh I had it
three one it's more and more optimistic
all the time about my chances to win
this match I haven't lost hope yet come
on okay
no
[Music]
oh that was important
let's go
I shouldn't serve that serve please
serve it again
I'm starting to imagine the situation
when I jump plane
yes
turn up just don't give him there
he didn't mean a spot where he isn't
okay I'm ready yeah come on you better
be
[Music]
yeah exactly it worked
I wasn't ready for this
that's what I was ready for I can come
on
[Music]
oh no
the pressure is high oh
it's a match point a match point
[Music]
oh
thank you thank you thank you so the
well-deserved winner trophy
what did I choose
[Music]
this is what happens if you lose Otto's
enjoying his morning coffee imagine yeah
he's just sleeping this is the man I'm
trusting my life with are we gonna make
it
so yeah oh no okay okay we're set we're
set
[Music]
my heartbeat is actually getting a bit
higher like how I feel it
I've never seen animals so pale just
looking down from here I'm honestly
pretty scared for our friends are
leaving us behind
bye
okay let's go
okay I'm pretty scared
who's Boston
haven't seen him again
okay okay it's getting real
it's really getting real now
away
oh my god oh okay oh let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
that was crazy oh that was scary that
was definitely scary
over there looks like you survived too
oh there's me
we made it okay guys
remember to hit subscribe this was four
million special
just can't wait for five million
okay okay oh
that was scary